first of all
our purpose is to strengthen the bonds
between the world's democracies i think
we are approaching a new world order
where you have an autocratic camp led by
china and the democratic camp led by the
united states as our aim is to make
the democratic camp as strong as
possible
but how can you do that when there are
as you say enormous countries like china
like russia that aren't following
democratic principles
well
in the run-up to this summit we have
conducted an opinion poll
which is actually the largest the
broadest opinion poll ever done on
democracy and 80 percent
of people all over the world want to
live in democracy
and furthermore
the free world represents
around 60 percent of the global economy
so if we stand together
if we
can unite
then we represent a formidable force
that will create some respect in beijing
and moscow
even though that is the case that that
it seems that most people want to live
in a democracy every year more elections
are being dismissed aren't they
in 2022 do you think democracy is is
under threat
absolutely for the 16th consecutive year
we have seen um
a global decline in freedom and
democracy
so
i think it's time it's high time to turn
the tide
we cannot take freedom and democracy for
granted we have to fight for it and we
see that currently in ukraine
the ukrainian people is actually
fighting on behalf of all of us
and we must stop putin
otherwise he will not stop he will
continue
to
conquer
peaceful neighbors if he isn't stuck in
ukraine
well on the subject of ukraine and
president putin you were of course uh
secretary general of nato so you
understand it workings very well
are you comfortable with how nato has
dealt with what has happened in ukraine
or do you think they should have done
more
well i think we have a duty
to help the ukrainians with everything
they need the ukrainian people has the
will to fight is our duty to provide
the means to fight
and so far i've been
satisfied with the unprecedented unity
within the nato alliance and among
democracies
in the whole world
when it comes to delivery of weapons but
i think we can do more i think the
european union should cut off all
financing of
putin's war machine it's a good step to
introduce an embargo of oil but that
should be followed by an embargo of gas
no oil no gas purchase in russia that
would bring
putin's war machine to its knees
has nato been emboldened do you think by
what putin has done of course you've
seen sweden and finland now talking
about membership
which they they had not done considered
for such a long time
yeah absolutely i mean
putin has achieved exactly the opposite
of what he wanted he has
uh against this sad backdrop of an
invasion in ukraine he has
created more unity within nato and now
he will also see nato being enlarged
with finland and sweden he gets
nato troops closer to
russian
borders so all in all
thanks to putin against this very sacked
sad backdrop
we have seen as strengthened nato
and in terms of countries doing more to
stop putin and nato doing water stop
putin in terms of embargoes do you think
the uk is doing enough is there anything
more you would like to see us doing
i think the uk has been at the very
forefront
of helping ukraine i also appreciate
the regular
updates on intelligence provided by the
uk
so i think
ukraine can really count the uk among
its closest friends and that may also be
necessary once the war is over
we have to ensure
that it will never happen again that
ukraine will be invaded so ukraine will
need security guarantees one way or the
other and i think the uk as well as the
u.s and other big nato allies will play
a crucial role in providing
a iron-clad security guarantees
to ukraine
how do you talk about the war being over
how do you think it will play out do you
see an end game
well i think the biggest risk right now
is a prolonged conflict
uh because putin and russia
are experts
in
prolonged simmering frozen conflicts for
decades they have uh occupied and eat
the eastern part of moldova since 2008
they have occupied applications south of
theater in the state of georgia since
2014 they have been in the crimea and
the eastern part of the runway region so
i think
putin's
goal might be
to continue to destabilize and weaken
ukraine through a prolonged
conflict i think this is currently the
biggest risk and that's why we have to
deliver all the weapons that ukraine
needs
we we have delivered some weapons
haven't we but also although we are not
delivering fighters um officially there
are some people who've gone in there
unofficially from the uk to fight and
two of those british soldiers we know
have been captured by by the russians
possibly now facing the death penalty is
there any hope for them that you can
offer to their families what what do you
think the international community could
do here
obviously we should do all we can to put
pressure on
russia but i'm not in a position to
to be too optimistic in that respect we
have seen how russia
violates
all international laws and
conventions
so i think the best
tool would be to continue
a maximum pressure uh on
russia the only language
that putin understands is a language of
strength
force and unity that's why we should
continue to put a maximum of pressure on
russia through delivery of all the
weapons
and cutting off all financing of
russia
but is there not also the danger that if
you do push back too hard um that he
then escalates it further
no on the contrary i think history has
taught us
that appeasement with dictators does not
lead to peace on the contrary it leads
to
war and
conflict
and i've noted that someone
has proposed that it
would be dangerous to humiliate
putin but i mean
setting the precedent
that an aggressor
can achieve their total gains
through
a peace deal after pursuing an
unjustified
war that will only encourage other
dictators as well it would set it would
send a very dangerous uh signal so i
think we have only one thing to do to
continue
helping the ukrainians to win this war